my name is Todd Reichert Daniel Bigham
is on zoom' right now and he will be
giving the presentation this talk is
going to be about our implementation of
using Wolfram language to build our ERP
system ERP data is basically business
data so well I will go ahead and just
turn it over to Daniel and then
hopefully he can finish on time and then
we can have a little QA so Daniel you
want to take over sure all right right
so like many organizations Wolfram
research has a RP system for our
business data it is fairly old I think
it was started about 20 years ago and so
a curiosity arose some time ago what it
would look like if we were to kind of
rebuild that system in the Wolfram
language and what would the benefits of
that being so there are some good
reasons to be curious about that because
the design tenants of the Wolfram
language have been very successful about
using things like intelligent defaults
automating as much as possible and
things like natural language and those
are things that we figure would be quite
useful in a in a business system as well
so the way that we represent data in the
kernel is simply as associations or
rather nested associations so here's an
example of a person entity with various
properties and then notice that the cats
here are actually associations as well
and they're nested within the person so
that's very powerful because you can
have a list of those to get a data set
you can there are lots of operations
from
I can so yeah there's lots of good data
operations in the Wolfram language for
slicing and dicing lists of associations
but where it really begins is defining
our entity types symbolically so here we
have a person and a cat and their
properties and the types of those
properties and once you do that there's
actually a lot of stuff that you can
automate before I get into those things
let's just look at the core operations
that we support for working with data so
these are things relating to storing or
and retrieving data so here I have a
person entity and I'm gonna call entity
create to store that in the database and
what comes back is the same thing but
notice that there have been ID
properties annotated on each of the
entities and that tells us that this is
now something that actually corresponds
to something in a database so then we'll
call entity get to retrieve those from
the database and I can give a single
condition or I can give a composite
condition and then of course there are
operations from modifying and deleting
the modify operation is kind of
interesting because you can give it all
the properties or however many you want
of your entity and it will return back
to you an indication of what it was that
actually changed okay so I was saying
that there is a lot that you can infer
if you have a good symbolic
representation of your entity types we
can create database tables and link them
together with appropriate foreign keys
but perhaps more interestingly it also
gives us the opportunity to evolve that
database schema automatically for you
over time so imagine you've got a person
dot WL file that defines this person
entity type and you want to add a new
property called last name rather than
interacting with a database or issuing
commands to do this you can just edit
your file and run a smart reload
function and that will intelligently
figure out what files have been modified
and not only that what it was that you
changed about your entity type so to
demonstrate that in this case I have the
old expression in the new expression and
this is just showing how we're able to
to figure out what has changed and then
reduce the change for the database
schema and then perhaps best of all the
ability to run a single deployment
function to target an enterprise private
cloud and to push those schema changes
when you're ready so that your EBC is
up-to-date so let's just go through a
lot of the things that can be automated
or streamlined with a good
representation of your entity types as
mundane as it is it's useful to not have
to write your own validation code in
this case of the property last name has
been misspelled and we get an indication
of that it's also an interesting example
of where the Wolfram languages symbolic
nature is quite handy in an ERP system
because it allows us to generate code or
to write code that writes code so what
I'm doing here is I'm taking the person
entity type and I'm asking for a pattern
that can be used to validate that and so
here's a pattern involving alternatives
and repeated null and so on and once we
have that we can just call match queue
and it can do the the quick initial
validation for us and it does it very
fast between 20 and 70 times faster than
if you were to loop over the properties
and do it manually we can also produce
entity types sorry this is a bit
pixelated the zoom change affected that
so you'll you'll want web you eyes to be
able to go in and view your entity types
and do add edit and delete operations
and so here we're using functions in the
Wolfram language like form function but
the nice thing is we're not having to
you know construct those manually they
can be generated from your entity types
automatically likewise with Web API is
an enterprise software it's pretty
common to need to do things like
serialization and deserialization we've
already talked about validation and then
you know passing these things around to
various web api's so we have some
built-in api's so the core data
operations that I was showing you such
as entity create we have web API is for
all those things so let's call an EPC
via this Web API to create somebody
named Paul and we get a response back
and JSON and then we'll do a query using
the entity get endpoint to find that
entity
so obviously we can do modifies and
deletes as well but in addition we want
it to be very easy to create your own
API so here's a silly little API called
acquire cats and what I want to point
out here is that unlike most API
functions where you just be passing
around scalars like integers and strings
this allows you to actually pass
entities like person and a list of cats
here and you're not needing to do any of
the validation there or serialization or
G serialization we take care of that for
you and additionally for things like
deployment you can now just call your
deployment function and because you've
associated that API with an endpoint
name we can deploy that to your EPC at
the appropriate endpoint for you and
then just to demonstrate this validation
I'm gonna call a local mock copy of this
and again this last name property has
been misspelled and so it's going to
take care of detecting that and telling
the caller that there's a problem
logging is another interesting area for
us a lot of projects will just write
flat text files for logging but then you
need to do a lot of grepping and and and
looking around but what we do is we
leverage the Wolfram languages ability
to easily you know take structured
information and pull it put it onto disk
and pull it back out again so that what
we're logging are is actually structured
and we inject logging into all the web
assets like API functions and and form
pages and so on so here's an example of
a call to a form page that didn't go so
well unfortunately grammar apply
returned a message but that is detected
and logged and then we have a nice way
to view that later and even to see the
stack trace and so on perhaps best of
all we actually take that structured
information and put it into the database
so that you can later do structured
queries just like you would for your
entity types to pull out logging
information and so here's an example
where we're putting that into a data set
for easy viewing
so let's look at synchronization we've
got a couple ways that we have we work
with external databases we enterprise
software is often in a world where you
have a variety of different systems that
all want to integrate with one another
here's an example where we want to on a
daily basis ingest a bunch of employee
entities from an external system so the
way that this works in this case is that
we write the code to pull that data in
and then we turned it into these nested
associations for these entities and I
just want to point out that there's a
special property here called external ID
which is the ID of this entity in the
external system and also notice that
there's again nesting going on so we
have phone number entities that are
nested within the employee there are
organization levels and so on now all
these things exist as separate database
tables but you're not needing to worry
about that you just create this
structure yourself and once we have that
hmm we just call entity sink and it will
take care of pulling that into the
database now when I pull the employees
back out notice that they now have local
IDs in our database but we didn't have
to write any SQL code to do this
synchronization ourselves now another
way of working with external systems is
where you want the data to stay on the
external system but you'd like to be
able to write queries that bridge
multiple databases so in this case we
define a contact entity type with the
first name last name email addresses we
then define a second kind of concrete
data type that inherits those properties
from contact and then adds in that
special external ID property again but
from there we also need to define an
import mapping so we indicate what
database this external entity will be on
the table on that database and then we
define a property mapping that map's
from our properties to the fields in
that database table so for external ID
and phone number the mapping is very
simple but for email addresses it gets
more complicated because there's
actually a joint involved so we define a
column path that gives the kind of the
path through
the various tables and fields to end up
at the email addresses table and the
email address field within that table
but once we've done that it's it's
pretty impressive because we can
construct a query where we can say give
me the licenses where the registered
user has a contact where one of the
email addresses is this one here and for
it to execute this what it first needs
to do is break the query into two pieces
this piece it will execute in the
external database to get the X the
external IDs and then it will compose a
second query to run in our local
database to do the full query and then
we get the results back here and and
again what's what's nice about this is
that it's a uniform layer of abstraction
for you you're not needing to worry
about which part of the query is
external or which part is local all
right so let's take a look at natural
language so I'm gonna break this down
into two parts this part is called
direct qualification so when you there's
a technology in the Wolfram language
called PLI the function is called
grammar apply and that allows you to
create grammars to do natural language
but rather than having you write those
grammars automatically we generate those
grammars so we have an entity type
called order and so we can call our
natural language function and it can
create a symbolic representation for
that without any kind of custom work on
your side here's an example where we're
qualifying orders by Amazon and what it
figures out is that we can qualify the
source property of order by Amazon and
it creates again this symbolic
representation in this case we want
business-to-business orders but we
wanted to tailor the linguistic so I'm
just going to go into this entity type
here and show you that there's an entity
an entity that has been given some
custom linguistics to allow it to be
referred to as just b2b once we've done
that we can do b2b orders and it knows
how to interpret that and here's an
example where we're qualifying orders by
two things Amazon and E to see and now
it's qualifying to properties all right
where it gets more interesting is
indirect qualification so with the query
mathematical orders what's complicated
about that is that orders contains
thing called configured product as a
nested entity and that contains a
version product the version product
contains a product and then finally that
thing has a name Mathematica so you need
to go through multiple hops of nesting
to be able to qualify orders by
Mathematica so what we do is we
construct in math you'd call it a graph
where the nodes of that graph are the
entity types and the edges between those
nodes are the properties and it can
search that graph to find the proper
multi-step qualification - to symbolize
mathematical orders and even better you
can take the output of that NLU function
and pass that to entity cat and it knows
how to execute that query on the
database to pull back the results all
right so where we went from there is we
realized that you know a lot of what
you're wanting to do in the enterprise
are actions or workflows but actions are
actually similar to entity types or they
are you can think of them that way so
here we have one called system transfer
which if somebody installed mathematic
on one computer but wants to switch it
over to another one they may need to get
in contact with their customer service
but for us to do that for them we need
to find their activation key and make a
change to that so we model this entity
as a system transfer entity type with a
property activation key and then we
write an action function which is the
thing that we will give this system
transfer entity to once we have its
activation key filled in and and our
business logic will live in here but
before we can actually execute this we
need to figure out for a given customer
what activation key entity do we need to
fill in here and that's where the
natural language and indirect
qualification comes in handy so system
transfer for Daniel B at Wolfram comm
I'm going to execute that here and what
it will do is it will again search that
graph to come up with a symbolic
representation for that query in this
case there's actually a nested ambiguity
list because there are two paths within
the database which are valid for for
qualifying an activation key by an email
address so it's done that notice again
that this actually involves
an external database but that's kind of
hidden by this abstraction so let's see
what that would look like using web UI
to do this workflow we'd type in system
transfer and then click Submit it's
going to create the symbolic
representation go out to the database
and see which activation keys can be
concurrent concretely filled in here and
it's going to find that that daniel has
two products and so the web UI is going
to display a screen to say choose which
activation key we want to perform the
system transfer on so the user would
click here and now we have all the
information that we need to create a
final system transfer entity to call
that action function that we talked
about and it can produce the final
results saying system transfer complete
for this activation key so what we're
realizing is that that really is a
common thing in organizations you know
you've got these workflows that you want
to do you can typically kind of initiate
those using a fairly simple phrase that
you can type in it often involves some
indirect qualification but once you have
the appropriate symbolic representation
you can execute on that and it's an
efficient way to go through a workflow
okay so the final thing that I want to
look at our inference rules and how you
can use those to create clean UIs so
here's a simple inference rule it has
two parts this is a pattern and this is
the conclusion so if the pattern is
matched we want to apply the conclusion
so what we're saying is that if
Mathematica is being purchased and the
use type is government or commercial
then the number of front-end and
parallel kernels that that user is
entitled to is is described here here's
a more complicated example where we're
saying if they're purchasing a
Mathematica Network then the number of
processes they get is actually a
function of the number of seats that
they're purchasing for their network and
the fact that the Wolfram language
supports things like peer functions
makes it very natural to be able to
express this and we don't need to write
you know like a custom parser to load in
these rules it just just
works as is when we read these in so
those those are examples now let's
actually run one of these we have a what
we call a configured product here of a
mathematical network with two seats and
when we apply the inference rules to
that you can see that it fills in these
various properties with values according
to those inference rules now once we
have that it makes it quite
straightforward to build UIs
so what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to create an empty Association for
a configured product that I would like
to get populated and I'm going to
populate that using a UI so I have this
dynamic entity form function I say that
we're gonna be working with the entity
type configured product I give it my
empty Association then I give it a list
of properties that I would like to have
to be UI fields and notice that in most
cases I don't need to give a lot of
detail or any detail at all about what
this property means what its valid
values are what its type is those kinds
of things because those are represented
within the entity type itself so I just
run this and I'm going to type in
Mathematica and you can see I have a
show entity true here so it's showing me
the Association that's getting kind of
populated as I go through the UI now
when I select Network it can now run
those inference rules that I was talking
about before but the UI didnt need to
encode these directly those live right
within the entity type when I give the
number of seats that can now do more of
that inference rule because it has
enough to now compute final number of
compute and control processes and then
just to round things off all finish
configuring my product and now I have
the final symbolic representation of my
my nested Association here and as one
final last step here I'm going to take
this and this association that I've
created I'm going to pass it to a
function called calculate price and then
grab the price and I get my results
that's just an example of how to create
a simple UI based on an entity type to
to populate an association and then you
can run business logic on that so
just to round things out here I think
our conclusion is you know we started
off with this curiosity of would the
Wolfram language in fact be fertile soil
for creating a symbolic ERP system and I
think everybody on the team thinks that
the answer is yes that it there's um the
language really is well suited for doing
this kind of thing not just for
scientific computation but also for
representing business objects and
creating rich layers of abstraction and
natural language and that sort of thing
so all those they're all right Thank You
Daniel so as you see oh I got beeped
call me I got five minutes left so the
we could go into detail about a lot of
this this was a very the technical side
you know we're we're about eighteen
months into this we're building the
framework the building blocks for this
and and really the framework that
Daniels been building here with the team
is going to have more uses than just in
the RPC system